So let's learn how to edit content directly in the browser.
So you can either follow along one to one with this if you have the Unreal Engine open
or you can just watch completely up to you.
But for now I'm just going to find an asset in my content drawer.
So I'm going to hit control and space bar and I'm going to scroll to the starter content
because I included starter content and I'm going to go to the props folder.
Now what you could do is to get used to some of this functionality you could select content
for example, go over to the filter button and click that and then go to static mesh.
And if I click static mesh it will show all the static meshes that are available to me
inside the browser.
So you might already have some interesting meshes to work with.
You might have say for example this damage cart which when I drag it in it's going to
prepare the shaders and build everything and so you might have some more interesting meshes
than I have at hand.
But I'm just going to delete that.
I'm going to go to starter content, I'm going to go to props and I'm going to go to the
basic chair.
Now the chair by default faces away from me.
So the first thing I want to do is rotate it towards me.
So you'll see this widget here which is a transform widget so I can move up, down, left,
right.
So I'm going to move around my viewport by right mouse buttoning and panning my camera.
So holding right mouse button pans the camera.
Left mouse button goes backwards and forwards and holding both mouse buttons goes up and
down.
So right mouse button plus left mouse button and then just getting the viewport into position
you want it to be.
I don't want to move the location of this, I want to move the rotation.
So I'm going to press spacebar and you'll see that I have the translate widget here
and when I hit spacebar it will go to rotate.
So spacebar is going to rotate and if I press spacebar again it goes to scale.
So you can see it toggling through these three widgets.
So I always use spacebar rather than going up to the top here but that covers these three
widgets here.
So I'm going to go to rotate, I'm going to click left mouse button, drag and rotate
the chair to a nice angle.
Maybe I want to scale it down, let's go to the middle of the scale and let's scale it
down.
Now that chair went way too small for the purposes here.
So this lets us introduce snapping.
So you'll see we've got grid snapping at 10, we've got rotation snapping at 10 and
we've got scale snapping at 0.25.
Now the scale at 0.25 was way too severe so I want to maybe bring it to 0.625 and then
now when I scale it will scale much more gradually and I can get a much nicer result.
So that's about right.
So it's just below one and it's just like that's the perfect size for me.
So when I'm snapping whether on the rotation or the grid you can edit each one of those
dependent on the values here.
Now grid snapping is really useful and so I'm going to press spacebar and you'll see
that my chair moves and it feels like it's snapping and that's because of the grid snap
10.
Now another good functionality of the Unreal Engine is to toggle the grid snapping.
You'll be doing this more frequently I think than the rotation scale but I'm going to hit
the brackets keys next to the enter on my keyboard.
So I'm going to do close bracket for larger and open bracket for smaller.
So just toggle between the two grid sizes and you can see the grid size going up and
down and again I'm just using the brackets keys on my keyboard next to the enter key.
And so now if I set that to 100 it's going to be snapping at 100 and if I set it to 500
it's going to be snapping at 500 units.
So very powerful functionality.
I'm going to snap it here but the one last thing that's frustrating me about manipulating
this content is that it's transforming it in world location.
It's just going left to right up and down but I rotated this chair on an angle.
So how do I change my widget to match the angle?
And that's the last button here that I want to cover which toggles between world transform
and local transform.
So I'm going to toggle this to the local transform and now you'll see it gives me much better
control because it's moving the chair forwards and backwards depending on where I want it.
So hopefully that gives you a good overview of how to add an asset to the scene or you
can use the different widgets to get the content working exactly how you want it to and that's
how to essentially place actors and start manipulating the content.
One last tip though might be worth covering is the camera speed.
So as you're getting more familiar with navigating the interface your right mouse button into
pan around, left mouse button in to dolly backwards and forwards and then both mouse
buttons to move around.
You can also be pressing W, A, S and D on the keyboard.
So W to move forward, S to move backwards, A to move left, D to move right and these
are more traditional PC based controls for editing viewports.
So W, A, S and D I'm now flying around the scene holding right mouse button down.
So again it might take a little bit of time to get used to it but just getting familiar
with that it'll become second nature in no time.
But you'll see as I'm flying around the camera is moving a little bit quick for me.
I want to get a bit slower into this chair so I'm going to select the camera speed, I'm
going to bring the camera speed down to two and now you'll see I'm moving much slower.
So that's really useful to know.
And then a little bonus tip rather than keep going back to the camera speed I always like
to scroll the middle mouse wheel on my mouse so that when I'm moving around I'm scrolling
it up and I'm going faster.
So I've scrolled my mouse wheel up and I'm moving faster.
If I scroll it down it'll really make me move slower.
So editing the content, scrolling the wheel and just getting really familiar with the
W, A, S and D on the keyboard, the left and right mouse buttons on your mouse and then
the mouse wheel will really help you edit your content much faster when you get familiar
with that workflow.